hello friends I'm Alan and welcome to my
channel today i'm making a video i'm
actually very excited to make i think
this is gonna be a fun one i've had this
planned for ages for so long but some of
the things i'm going to read
i've just had in a folder and haven't
read in probably a year so some of this
is gonna be fresh for me too
basically the plan for this video is i
am taking some instagram dm's what
people have asked me on a date or
propositioned me in some way and
literally rating them based on their
effectiveness before we get into this
there are two things that I really want
to clarify one I'm actually genuinely
not making this video with any intention
of making fun of these people I'm
actually trying to give advice of course
when it comes to asking anyone out on a
date this advice applies to me I cannot
speak on behalf of everyone ever
everyone has different tastes but no I
want to be very clear that I don't think
any of these people well I don't feel
like most of these people have done
anything wrong I do not think there is
anything at all wrong with asking a girl
out on the Internet with sending someone
a DM with telling someone you find them
attractive I don't think there's like
literally any problem with that you are
not doing anything wrong you find not
here to make fun of you just trying to
be helpful
number two this video does not mean that
I read my damns and I want to be very
clear about that I've been collecting
these for probably almost a year now I
probably get a hundred Instagram DMS
every day it is the only platform where
I have Dan's open because you can't
close them but they still go to my other
folder so I do not see vast majority of
them I don't look very often so I want
to be very clear that sending me a DM
the chances of me reading in a very low
if you have any professional or business
requests definitely don't send them
there may be a one percent chance that I
will read it okay with those things out
of the way let's get to it first message
if I was closer I take you for coffee
and let everyone watch a slow dance in
the middle of the street he sends me
another message at 5 p.m. the next day
saying just did a weird dare thing I
have to admit who I wanted to make love
to gamer wise for the past few years so
yup definitely would never work on me
one big thing with this one is this dude
has a private profile I think there's
something very odd about someone with a
private profile propositioning you if
your profile is public so if you can see
a bunch of information about me you know
who I am
but then you tell me you would like to
go on a date and all of your information
is private and your message just says
hey I want to take you out for coffee
dance with you and have sex with you but
doesn't actually tell me anything about
your personality who you are as a person
there is virtually just no incentive
incentive for me to do that if anything
I would be worried about my personal
safety I know so little about you as a
person based on what you've sent to me
that there's just no way that I would
reply to that okay next
listen let's skip the small talk dating
engagement and let's get married two
weeks and five days from today I'm in
the military so I got you with health
care housing and food sounds good all
right awesome I'll see you in two weeks
and five days wife because I think this
is funny and I'm running on the
assumption that this man is not being
serious and does not actually want to
marry me it is instead kind of a
creative way for him to tell me his job
but also you know being confident also
cool with this one my granddad proposed
to my grandma on the night that he met
her she naturally said no but they were
together until he passed away there's a
long time this one's fine we're cool
with it
next should I stop this with the cheesy
pickup line
um did it hurt when you fell from the
vending machine because you be looking
like a snack Mike drops I'm sorry in
advance good joke bad pick-up line in
that we all know you read it somewhere
else pick up lines of generic I don't
think they show any of your personality
and I also think this one like just
something about his grandma his um and
then his I'm sorry in advance doctor
lull just implies a little too much
awkwardness for me be more confident
show me your actual personality pickup
lines I think like you know we also
regurgitate it come across as a sort of
like this somebody had conversation with
someone recently who said one of their
friends go to pickup lines at a bar or
whatever was I like your face sure he's
still using it on a lot of women in
theory but saying I like your face
actually would get me to engage in
conversation with someone because it's
such an unusual thing to say where is a
pick-up line like did it hurt when you
fell from a vending machine because you
look like a snack is like yeah okay
this is it's just a little too generic
you know it get creative with it next is
hey I know this is a complete shot in
the dark and hopefully it doesn't come
off it's creepy but if you're ever in
the San Diego area I'd love to take you
out to dinner
that's this Italian place I'm not gonna
mention it and then he says it's
absolutely fantastic
superboy big fan of his grandma that's
an important one for me but that's
obviously very personal I'm probably
gonna spend a lot of time texting you if
I'm dating you you got it you gotta get
that down so this one is a nice message
I approve of the way that he did it but
again this is very little indication of
sort of why I should go out to dinner
with you and I know that's like a very
weird reality of dating it's probably
for the most part you know it's not
actually in my experience but for the
most part men after shooing women
genuinely when I'm pursuing someone the
person I people I end up dating it is
usually the other way around I'm usually
one pursuing them and of course I have
also been rejected happens to everyone
but you do have to make yourself from
stand out from everyone else for some
reason so nice message but nothing
attention-grabbing about it really
similarly the next message is hey
gorgeous I'd like to take you out to
dinner sometime I just want to meet your
personality I think like I just want to
meet your personality is the thing
that's like I get why you are asking to
do this I feel like I understand that by
you sending me this message you want to
take me out to a date why do I want to
say yes that's what you got to tell me
gotta give me a little bit more you know
a little bit more next up you up you are
only of the most beautiful girls I've
ever seen but more than that you seem to
have absolutely no idea I can't decide
if I find that lovable or sad but I do
know I'd love to finally give you
someone who can show you your Worth and
get you smiling more I've got a house in
LA with two businesses and a tongue Wow
I definitely forgot about this one and a
tongue that's a big part of the reason
no girl has ever left me let me know if
you want to get a drink this weekend I
mean it for some reason I think I
blushed reading that despite the fact
that I make dirty jokes basically for a
living I don't know why that Wow okay
let's break this one down hey thanks for
calling me beautiful this is something
that I I have a big pet peeve with and I
don't know if it's
just me but it happens all the time it's
when people like project this like weird
[ __ ] on to my state of mind and try to
tell me how I feel and how I should feel
about how I feel I like to call them
diagnosis man because it is someone
projecting so much onto you I'm very
happy right now I got this message like
this week I'm very happy right now
it's someone being like you seem unhappy
I know it's best for you like who
thought [ __ ] you know but also every
diagnosis man has a different diagnosis
that they all genuinely very much
believe based on what they've seen of
you I find that very unsettling in a
weird way so you definitely lose me on
this message with I can't decide if I
find that lovable a sad but I do know
I'd love to finally give you someone who
can show you your worth and get you
smiling ball if your pitch to dating me
is making it sound like I hate myself
which I do not I think I come across
that way sometimes because as an
Australian my humor is very
self-deprecating don't actually hate
myself but then he also like bragged
about having a house in a business and
that stung he's part of a reason no girl
has ever left him ooh love this one
wonder if you would have a data
professional working man who's big into
gaming like me or do you only date guys
who live in the gym and work out 24/7
even if they have no personality long
shot but let me know if you want to grab
coffee and date someone who actually has
something in common with you if you play
games as much as you say you do I think
this man is trying to nag me I'm sure
that strategy works on some people I
can't imagine wanting to hang out with
someone who would be like no you only
date guys who go to the gym his shtick
is I actually play video games you are
gonna love hanging out with me doesn't
work I don't care how much games you
play okay next one hey Alanna you don't
know me but from what I can tell we have
a lot in common I even have a Batman
tattoo and I collect first four figures
and Hot Toys you probably don't read
your DMS and nobody famous but if you
never like to be taken on a date in
downtown LA I'd love to have your
company Thanks I love this one actually
this might be the best one I've read yet
he acknowledges that I don't know him
that's that's a berry that we've broken
and he probably knows who I am he
specifies some of the stuff we have
in common that mean that we immediately
have talking points that I could reply
to this damn if I were single and
interested or whatever and I could be
like oh cool what do you collect like
what's your favorite first full figure
what's your favorite hot toy like he's
he's given me something to respond to
and then if you'd ever like to be taken
on a date in downtown LA I'd love to
have your company use such a polite way
of asking someone out it's like if you
would like to I would love to have your
company it's just this is just very nice
and then he says thanks the next one
just says meet for coffee I feel like
we've been over by this point no you me
this Friday the best pizza in LA I'd bet
you've never tried it I like this one
too actually got the confidence that's a
big thing he's also like technically
started a competition in a way where he
but not not in a way that's
condescending he's been like but you've
never tried it which prompts me to be
like all what is it maybe I have tried
it but in no way that's aggressive or
nagging or whatever so again cool with
this one okay next we have I know you
probably get this a lot but god I'm in
love with you I think I'm in love with
you I love you you're amazing can I take
you on a date at least we each like a
month apart listen if you start with I'm
in love with you I'm gonna think that
there's something off about you because
you have to remember you don't know me
you know what I show you on the internet
and I think based on that you can build
an idea of who I am but that does not
mean that that idea is true by any means
so it's just a bit much
you gotta tone that down okay hello I
was just wondering what type of flowers
you would like on our first date I like
this one I'm a fan again
confidence but also he's asking me a
question good stuff
okay if you ever got a plane ticket for
me to come over to California I def take
you out for dinner cuz you were
beautiful and a nerd perfect combo he's
asking me to fly him to California so he
can take me on a date not your finest
work
I look I have a lot more of these if
people really like this video I may be
able to a part to you but I'm absolutely
going to end on this one because this is
the best okay this guy sends a message
30th of January 2016 he says why do
people say they want to rape you
he follows up maybe in a Lolita and says
that's mean he sends me another message
in 2019 it says I was 13 when I said
that I'm now 17 sorry I love it
incredible that's the best alrighty
everyone I'm gonna wrap it up in you
might do it but do it people enjoy this
feel like this video is probably gonna
be sort of controversial I'm gonna have
a lot of people in the comments be very
angry at me about how I feel about this
kind of stuff because yeah I mean I feel
like some people can be very sensitive
about watching someone talk about why
they do or do not to choose to date
other people but I'm hoping that at
least some of you find it helpful of
course it's still really subjective it
really is just my opinion maybe all the
women agree with me on my stance here I
don't know I think they probably do at
least a certain number of them alrighty
everyone I'm alone I hope you guys
enjoyed this video I'll see you guys
next time okay